ich habe ja nur so über ganze ganzen
film
kraus oder aus der bahn oder irgendwas
aber wir sind jetzt gerade kann hoffen
berlin tegel angekommen mit maskottchen
kontakt des katasters den kickflip
gesehen doch mal ein looping oder
irgendwas
ich habe sich gesehen war normal das war
richtig klasse
ebenfalls werden jetzt gleich unseren
privaten privatjet abgeholt und dann
geht es direkt weiter wo auch immer
deswegen wird gekauft ich kann selber
fliegen ich bin auch nachts geflogen
so voll war ein israeli die move on
geben jetzt zu einem restaurant noch
etwas essen weil ich heute noch gar
nichts gegessen habe und der marcel
möchte euch noch etwas sagen abonniert
nummer eins wie soll ich mir die nase
immer als bisher hier wäre einfach
scheiß wetter wir laufen jetzt gerade
so freuen ich bin jetzt endlich im
hotelzimmer angekommen wir waren gerade
noch bei einem kurzen meeting sag ich
mal einfach so weil noch nicht mehr zu
sagen darf das erfahrt ihr im september
und jetzt bin ich gerade endlich im
hotelzimmer angekommen ich werde jetzt
zum letzten gelder fahren mit zwölf mit
herr bergmann mit case mit delay oder
werde ich nachher noch auf eine party
gehen und ich nehme euch natürlich da
jetzt erstmal mit hinter diesen
unterwegs in den streets of berlin dpa
das essen gut und zwar hier sonne dünner
box dünner imbiss niemann und wir werden
jetzt zum lpt gehen und dann nehme ich
euch jetzt auch mit den weg zu fall
wir schreiben immer noch heute den
donnerstag
ich bin dabei dafür kommt auch gleich an
lassen dass wir den plätzen jedenfalls
ist welche beim ept dabei da fühl mich
wahrscheinlich auch das ein oder andere
sind da nicht lang und eine klinik wie
oft habe ich das als mischung sagt sie
doch und deren kleid mit wunderbaren
neuen sneaker sehen den moskitos aber
die kosten
hier dann noch ein paar mosel von
jamaica das total toll was wir sind
jetzt gerade dass die aufgenommen wird
und freue mich wenn ich alleine sondern
zusammen mit der lieben sturm würfel
guter kontakt dann haben wir da vorne
dass ein paar leute die dir überall
rumsitzen und komiker macht und davon
ist auch der bergmann
die haben wir noch überall leute überall
leute am start und da hinten sehen wir
gerade was gerade in dem anderen raum da
vorne stattfindet und zwar spiele gerade
größer gleich kommen dazu und was wir da
vielleicht machen falls sie nicht genau
aber vielleicht bin ich da etwas ein
wir waren jetzt gerade hier beim lpt zu
gast ja wahrscheinlich gerade ein paar
szenen davon gesehen
wir laufen jetzt an einem ort wo wir
grillen ist es wieder hell freunde
laufen jetzt zu einem ort wo wir grillen
werden und da auch noch besprechen also
hier immer die ganzen tag unterwegs nach
werden wir noch auf die endemol partie
gehen werde ich falls ich da was filme
werdet ihr das dann nachher noch sehen
aber jetzt kommen erst ein paar coole
übergangs sehen
freunde schon wenn ich getroffen habe
bin ich froh und es ist wirklich die
ganze zeit an regnen
wir gehen jetzt grillen bei dem wetter
gerade in einem tollhaus muss
süßigkeiten und ich wollte ehrlich
gesagt oben sagen ich bin maler und echt
noch und jan gekommen
wir befinden uns gerade im sowohl besten
büro was ich wirklich gewinn habe ich
zeige euch das mal eben hier wir haben
ihr halt mal wieder im büro aber überall
stehen so gags rum wie das hier wird man
also die zähne raus nehmen muss und hier
also drohen wir haben hier werden
ameisen gezüchtet davon ist einfach so
ein keyplayer box sie haben hier überall
sachen die liegen überall bälle rum
alles gesagt wenn ihr überall
irgendwelche spielereien oder so was sie
haben auch einen afghanen hier ist auch
nerven geht es auch darum nach vorne
sind überall süßigkeiten und essen und
alles max wie wirst du dieses alles hier
in einem wort beschreiben wo alle
möglichen mutigsten stehen rtl wir haben
irgendwas komisch ist einfach auf bunte
zettel geschrieben produktiver sieht wir
sehen hier alle möglichen farben was da
drauf steht ist eher sowas wie milch
einkaufen oder so werden wir gespräche
die über drohnen für die haben die
ganzen dauerwerbesendung dann aber dies
ist aus ich kenne sie zusammen mit sp
wasser spontane aktion bei uns mit felix
roth bild ich hoffe euch hat dieser blog
hier vom ersten tag der video days
dingsbums hoffe das ganze hatte ich
irgendwie ein bisschen gefallen dass er
ihm identifizieren konnte mit diesem
blog jetzt hier vom ersten tag ich weiß
nicht ich will ich heute gefilmt aber
das war zu der erste block vom letzten
donnerstag die nächste kommt dann morgen
und dann sehen wir uns wieder wenn wir
auf den ersten moment recht lokalen dann
will ich mich über eine bewertung von du
hast letzten woche elf kinder